When it comes to your personal data and privacy settings,...
...you should be in control.
That's why Google Assistant helps you manage your preferences...
...simply by using your voice.
You can easily access privacy settings by asking questions like...
"Hey Google, how can I change my privacy settings?"
...and Google Assistant will help guide you...
...to the relevant privacy and security settings,...
...making it easier to find the resources you need.
To learn more about how Google is keeping your information protected,...
...you can ask questions like...
"Hey Google, how do you keep my data safe?"
...and hear more about how Google's built-in protections...
...keep your private information secure by default.
You can also get help with deleting interactions from your Google account.
Whenever you want your history cleared, you can say,...
"Hey, Google, delete everything I said to you last week."
...and Google Assistant will handle the rest.
Because when it comes to keeping your information...
...private, safe and secure, Google Assistant is here to help.